[Music]
a 20-18 Pew poll reports that a majority
of Americans on both the right and the
left say that higher education is headed
in the wrong direction and they're spot
on on the Left respondents say tuition
costs are too high
while college presidents have made
excuses and pointed fingers after
inflation costs have more than doubled
over the past 30 years as colleges
cheerfully spent heavily on amenities
athletics and bureaucracy on the right
those who see things going South Point
to politicize classrooms and
restrictions on campus speech behind the
many instances where Republican
sentiment has been treated as a thought
crime on campus is the inconvenient
reality too liberal faculty outnumber
conservatives five to one and that one
in three sociologists admit they'd be
less likely to hire a new professor if
he or she was a Republican
while there's little evidence that
public censure will prompt needed change
on campus it's reassuring to know that
Americans on both sides of the aisle are
seeing things clearly do you think
America's colleges are headed in the
wrong direction let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI